BRAD BIRD: That moment where
the character touches the pin
and finds herself
in the wheat field
was part of the film when
Damon pitched me the idea,
and that idea that this
better world was that close
was really attractive to me.
DAMON LINDELOF: This is
our view of "Tomorrowland."
It's a Disney movie.
It's coming out in the summer.
You know, we want
people to-- this
is-- he's enjoying his popcorn.
He's drinking.
He's drinking a
soda, more popcorn.
He's-- something's gone
down the wrong pipe.
He's clapping.
He's scared.
I feel like I'm on Pictionary.
It's terrifying.
We're going to do the rest
of this interview as--
BRAD BIRD: As Admiral Ackbar.
DAMON LINDELOF: That
will get feedback.
The views on YouTube
are going to shoot up.
Did you hear Bird did
a sit-down at Google
as Ackbar for two hours?